it's 2021 which means we are now
entering the start of the first year
with the next generation of consoles
both systems had
pretty solid launches except for you
know the
part where there wasn't enough supply
and no one could buy one
hopefully that changes soon but in the
meantime there are still
plenty of other things we want to see
out of the next generation to make it
even better
don't expect to see more games on this
list because it's kind of obvious and we
all know more games are coming out this
year
in fact if you want to watch a list of
the hottest games coming out in 2021
we already have a video of that and you
can go watch it right after this
we'd also appreciate a like and sub so
we can keep making more videos like this
for you
alright let's start with customization
we all love to customize our systems and
make them our own and right now
our options are rather limited taking a
look at the xbox ui we can see that it
is
the exact same as the previous
generation you can pick the color
and you can set an image as your
background the only thing different is
the new dynamic theme
which is nice looks good but it's not
enough
we'd love to see more dynamic themes
whether it's new patterns or
open up the floodgates for game specific
dynamic themes
similar to what we saw on the ps4 and
ps3
speaking of playstation the ps5 has
absolutely zero customization
this is a tricky one as games and apps
on the interface are
designed to fill the whole screen which
leaves
no room for customizable themes
the best we could get at the moment is a
change in color and music in the
settings menu which would be nice but
limited when compared to what people are
used to
coming from ps4 honestly hard to say if
we'll ever see a return to themes for
the ps5
but without a major update to the ui
it's unlikely for now
we also don't have much in the way of
hardware variety
either don't expect any crossover
designs for a couple years
but we could potentially get alternate
models that offer
more hard drive space something that the
ps5 in particular
really needs but again there are enough
issues keeping up with supply for the
current model so until that sorted we
might not get anything new
however we might get a few color options
most likely in the form of game specific
bundles like ones for payload infinite
or the new god of war
but we all know what we really want that
sexy black
ps5 we already know you're gonna give in
and make it at some point sony so stop
teasing and give it to us already
controller colors would also be nice in
addition to the black and white options
xbox already offers a blue controller
and recently revealed the
pulse red they're also bringing back
their custom controller store called the
xbox design lab sometime this year
no word from sony on alternate colors
for the dual sense and we'd like to see
some of it this year as well
ideally in black speaking of the dual
sense
it really is one of the best parts of
the ps5 i made a whole video
talking about how amazing its haptic
feedback and adaptive triggers are for
shooters it really does feel next gen
which makes the series x s controller
disappointing in comparison i do
actually quite like it
it's got a nice feel the d-pad is a big
improvement and i like the grips they
put on the triggers
but it still feels undeniably behind in
innovation when compared to the dual
sense
microsoft seems to have realized this
because in a recent survey they asked if
xbox owners
felt like they were missing out on
features that the playstation
controllers have
yes microsoft and you should absolutely
steal that
and put it into xbox controllers not to
say that xbox doesn't have a premium
controller of its own
the xbox elite controller comes with
plenty of its own unique features
but it doesn't come packaged with a
series x
s and it runs you almost 200
i think if microsoft really wants to
impress they need to up their game of
the standard controller that
everyone gets and honestly this would be
a win for ps5
owners as well adaptive triggers are
cool
but do take extra work to implement and
it might not feel worth it for
third-party devs to spend time on
features
only accessible for one system so if
both systems have it we're likely to get
it in more games which
will spread the wealth of that next-gen
feel that the
adaptive triggers and haptic feedback
bring now another concept that feels
truly next-gen is the ability to play
games with your friends regardless of
the platform they're on
that's right i'm talking about crossplay
which yes
is something we've seen more of in the
last several years but we still aren't
at the point where crossplay and cross
saves have become a standard feature
in most games i was really hoping for
crossplay to be a
big push with the next generation but
sony and microsoft haven't really done
anything on their end to encourage
crossplay leaving it up to developers to
implement it
i do believe crossplay will slowly
continue to grow but something that
would help push it forward
is a way for players to interact with
each other across systems
having the ps5 and series x slash s so
closed off from each other feels dated
at this point and what we need
is a unified friends list and party chat
system
otherwise we'll need to continue to rely
on individual developer and publisher
user accounts to make cross-play work
which is a huge pain on the consumer
level
i'm looking at you ubisoft connect i
don't
really expect microsoft and sony to play
nice and work directly with each other
but
perhaps a third party such as discord
could come in and help bridge the gap
now something that has been a major
focus of the next generation
is backwards compatibility microsoft has
been carrying over their excellent back
compat library to the series x
s and sony has been catching up by
making almost
all of the ps4s library available on ps5
but there's
always more both systems can do for xbox
that means bringing back their backwards
compatibility program which they put
on hold in 2019 so that the team could
focus on development for these series
consoles
now that the systems are out there's an
opportunity to bring back the program
after all there are still a couple xbox
360 games we'd like to see made
available and we've only ever got a
handful of xbox originals
and there are still a lot of great games
to mine from that generation
but even more importantly back when the
xbox one x came out
a number of back compat titles got
series x enhancements
letting these games run at native 4k if
you've checked out some of these games
like gears of war 3
or red dead redemption then you know how
transformative
these upgrades can be sadly that list of
games remains
rather small now is the perfect time to
bring back 4k enhancements to older
games on the ps5's end
there is admittedly less to work with
as much as i'd love to see them bring
back older generations such as the ps3
ps2 and even ps1 to the system i just
don't see it happening it requires
a lot of work on sony's part and they
seem pretty happy using ps now
as their way to play games from those
generations but
microsoft did surprise everyone with
their back compatibility program
so who knows a more realistic
expectation would be ps4 games getting
patches to take advantage of the ps5
hardware
goes to tsushima is the shiny example
where thanks to a patch
the game runs at 60fps even on its
resolution mode
giving you the best possible experience
meanwhile
god of war still makes you choose
between a high resolution at a locked 30
fps
or 60 fps but locked at 1080p
it would be nice to see more ps4
exclusives receive similar patches that
unlock their true potential
the way ghost of tsushima has games like
shadow of the colossus horizon zero dawn
bloodborne
death stranding the last of us part 2
bloodborne
uncharted 4 the last guardian and
bloodborne to name a few
but it is worth keeping in mind that
these patches would be dependent on the
developers of those games
and it's up to them to decide if it's
worth the time and money to go back and
patch them
so we'll just have to hope for the best
quick resume is a nifty little feature
on the series consoles that lets you run
multiple games at the same time
and switch back and forth between them
on the fly
but it's got some issues that need
sorting quick resume can run up to three
series x-s games at a time
or five for bat compatible games if
you're somebody that bounces between
games a lot it's possible to go over the
limit in which case the system will boot
older games off quick resume and shut
them down without
telling you adding a little notification
that lets you know your game is going to
close
would be quite helpful the other pain
about quick resume
is that currently not all games work
with it and there's no clear way to know
which do from the library which
kind of makes the whole feature a bit of
a gamble
until every game becomes compatible xbox
should add a
visual indication that the game is quick
resume compatible and you're safe to
leave the game on without fear of losing
progress
the ps5 doesn't have quick resume
we'd love to see it be added in a future
update if that's even possible
but keep in mind that quick resume
requires some hard drive space to hold
each game's
cash meaning the inclusion of such a
feature would further reduce the
system's already limited storage
capacity
speaking of limited storage there are a
few things the ps5 could do
to dramatically help gamers deal with
the limited space available
for one there is currently no options
for expanding the storage needed to play
ps5 games
ssds need to be fast enough to be
compatible and sony needs to properly
test
third-party ssds hopefully that
information comes out soon as
space is already running out another
thing sony should consider is letting
you store ps5 games on an external hard
drive
xbox series lets you do this and no you
won't be able to play the game
but at the very least you don't need to
delete it and re-download it
taking up precious bandwidth data no
option is present on the ps5
and you have no choice but to delete
your game if you need to make space
okay time to rapid fire a couple small
but important improvements we'd like to
see
the ps5 should add folder organization
to help players navigate their massive
libraries
xbox should let you claim your free
games with gold games without
automatically starting the download it's
annoying
and it should give people a prompt to
add to your library like the ps5 does
trying to quickly access the trophy list
of the game you're playing is not as
smooth of a process
as it is on ps4 and adding a trophy
option to the control center
to check your progress would help also
the trophy menu itself
has a rather large ui which makes
looking through the list
tedious adding an alternate view that
features a more condensed
list would be appreciated xbox series x
slash s's dedicated share button is a
nice improvement but the gallery menu
itself is a bit clunky and could use
some work
however major brownie points for the
gallery working with the xbox
phone app automatically sending
screenshots and videos there
it's absolutely something sony should do
with the ps5
and the playstation app okay
that was a lot if we missed anything you
want to see for the ps5 and xbox series
x slash
s go ahead and throw it in the comments
as a reminder if you want to see a video
listing the biggest next generation
games coming out this year
you can click on the link right here
have a wonderful day and
let's all hope that sony and microsoft
can sort out the whole supply and demand
issue soon
you